my father up in the sky high dive bomber
bomber Oh dummy house he's right next to
me jumped out he's dead but rising down
I got inspired him right I'll tangoing
as well rather low God bomber plane
flying plane whoa in there I don't know
oh my god thank you bro solo the explode
careful oh my god this is like a cinema
like this is a movie moment anyone who's
on foot anyone who's on foot don't
capture see me and there you'll go to
eat okay guys warming up my horse
quickly i'm popping off a bother coming
in bham bham dropping ammo on the way to
see you want to pick up ammo I'm just
healing with guys the storm coming in oh
yeah oh I'm gonna fight on this horse of
course combat me where T there come here
I'm coming up and down the fair few
people in thanks i'm on the toy panic I
can see them yet there you have to get
really close together
properly I've got 10 guys we've got 19
sort of nice oh the tank there i think
the town there's a tank on Charlie I
don't really know where it is I can't
see it gonna fix one down no yes oh my
god you got destroyed morning again and
see okay that was satisfying slipstream
I got on the horse asleep what are still
cooking malish oh no it's got one
answered don't kill me don't it cleaning
or how we gettin taken these lunch in
service clerk what I'll switch to
assault and come in with the anti-tank
grenades and dynamite zoo okay so you
think it's my time to Shelly yeah I
think so okay here we go I've got the AC
again you made oh nice well we're living
the sniper it's open the building
brought you up there and a cop at the
top yeah for the build a Smith where
what bizarre grenade but it down again
I'm back I'm kind not one back of seen
hours in the building I'm cutting some
down yea it's going on now and well no
Oh getting slightly take ya round shot
I'm putting in I'm making this building
dr.
thank you we're going with a ride is why
we're taking Charlie now guys well
that's the I'm behind you oh Jesus maybe
you need a little bit of like got one I
inside the building yes yeah ran over
him all my god jump right up in the air
there raglan and every Todd just running
San oh my god the explosions of real die
yep still a long oh god no I'm out boys
I need em oh oh oh it's leo it's the
fairly garment dist i yelling the be
point heavy shelling heavy shelling let
I don't let that Obama and there's a guy
coming from Oh them be as well let's
stick with let's stick on be for now cuz
it's being taken back here we go let's
get those penguin April I hear it 22
damage 44 yes dad great work nice one
boy enjoy slowly but I'm talking about
scale from am I with me hmm oh thank you
very much there's a light tank light
tank light tank yeah well I'm just gonna
focus on render our troops it's nothing
afterwards see this doctor it's suicide
for a few danica how are you going to
kill me like that no that was a great
tight town of the tank there guys that
was really good there's still people
that be yeah def getting all the guys in
my building society do reclaim back
again they taking it are there back
taking off wait taking it hope you're
taking it back now we're starting to
take it back i won't see you on see
we're taking seatbacks well yeah yeah
I'm there whoa did we got a couple so
boom out of the shot they an armored
vehicle coming across in this knife
snipe of the way back yeah I see there
you go salad that car completely
distracted me I think I got one I'm
ready for quarter come on yeah i'm
dropping on the Seelie for a second okay
okay that's my slide for a nice for on
you I die I'll Underwood right guys
let's go oh my cook what Justin we're
actually taking a work for taking pay as
well oh yeah we are okay why are some
ammo Oh what shot nice dick the tank in
my way blows onto the anti-personnel
tank is chipping lamb beef why they've
got about a lot just come to see you can
see with me nice to get someone with the
flamethrower people hurry over here all
get shot behind over mine quick tinkle I
got it we're losing g as well we're
losing gee I'm spawn wars on fire oh wow
it's loads of them let's see now big
trick do it hey man Oh
um all right yeah they're all in these
buildings before I enjoyed it no he
knows a lot of them yeah I Caillou
vectors P as well oh look there's four
here there's four guys right I'm pushing
on fishing i'm gonna it's not efficient
there we go nice one that is all that
take down that was taking the line
vehicle in all the jumping yeah okay I
got your whiskey Oh God this one's Phil
here was roaming this go go go what
light tank of me ah oh yeah at light
tank oh we're gonna get it was nice but
uh oh as soon as you said light tank on
the hill I was like crap we can I take
the arts too short of it up I disabled
it let us able the big BAM oh I've got
him it's gone nice nice right now so
what I'm go soon instant oh my god that
was a shot looky shot I've ever done in
my life but I'll take it alright wasn't
a fuken where we get this model of my
horse oh my going away haha other one I
missed yes sir Ironside typing oh nice
way nice someone help me there ya go got
it we got him yeah well I need to heal
up very quickly right charlie oh my god
that was nice I saw that kill I saw that
kill that was so good oh this is
particular phone oh my god no way did I
just get that kill long-range I saw a
smoked Lee they've just me buddy lifted
up the clam 054 let's go for a copay
okay nice oh they're good but book plane
my brave boy you guys get off we've got
a cavalry charge going three of us are
ways that would get sure
are in the top page wait I've got saber
right let's go take alpha here we go
there's a light tank in like tank don't
see you let's get this money's on it
yeah oh oh oh yes legend trevor the
flames did I get a kill oh yeah I got
the kill nice train is that alpha making
its way back now it's by a penguin well
thank you feel me oh no way did I just
get that killed totally crap like
completely no scope with the rifle on
the walls and just killed your driver in
front of the trucks yeah anything you
can do guys if I die will the mines for
me mines will c4 and diner or dynamite
won't repeat it they're trying to run in
as infantry on d I comment entering the
town from where from the town okay eat
the phone to the lot of snipers but I've
got I did a lot of damage I got our no
we only gonna die together grenades yeah
no way they found a little spa we're
still ahead on points at the moment so
we're not doing too badly
I didn't see it thank you to [ __ ] but to
find this guy that I can't guys it's
crazy nearly dead now I've got like
we're trying to make sure they don't
take see Benny's on e now he's fighting
another heavy tank this guy here why it
got one shot lab cmus guy here at seat
behind the wall we've taken just tagged
them up with you Benny easy cure Dean
owner is wanna see they are getting Dean
she's getting me every time where is he
where is he with he's all my dead body
now no no mr. and mrs. Olayinka run so
he crushed right lie down as a guide
only do what about with pistols Papa
Geppetto ya got CJ by ADA YZ oh that was
right in safe hands like a nose oh why
when he come friend hell to get me oh
bloody hell this is a craziest of the
realm anti-tank going at him synchrony
all got him got him hold it out that's
all he points to go I'm just hot on this
thing and there's in a divot 1.2 wrong
yo ed good job to confidence levels
probably still lower probably increased
my skills by about three percent I
thought he'd be a bit meaner but he's
actually very nice all focus we all
going from one place and other students
we've done one class we know what we're
doing next mainly blowing things up if
you're just running around like a
headless chicken and battlefield you
just gotta die I can't wait to get into
vehicles and ramp it up and get it into
gear and see how far we can go
play it first with EA access